he has a lucky even more of the dark
feelings Easter eggs he may have missed
on your first watch and if you haven't
seen the movie here's your warning
spoilers are ahead considering that the
x-men first class film already used the
Hellfire Club as antagonists the
filmmakers students have a whole lot of
options when it came to adapting the
Dark Phoenix storyline just as it
appeared in the comics especially since
the barely coded sexual undertones of
the club in the comics wouldn't exactly
make the group a good fit for a pg-13
film despite that they still managed to
sneak in a quick reference to the
original Chris Claremont and John Byrne
comics with one of Magneto's lieutenants
what is a guy who throws his hair braids
around his webs and shockingly doesn't
seem to be any one of the hundreds of
x-men characters featured in the comics
the other is a telepathic mutant named
Selene although she's only called that
the moment she's knocked out of the
train at the end of the film in the
comics Selena's been a frequent
antagonist to the x-men and has
occasionally been the black queen of the
Hellfire Club comic Selene is also an
immortal psychic vampire it might be the
world's very first mutants predating
name or apocalypse and Wolverine movie
Selene it doesn't have much in common
with the comics counterpart but it's a
nice nod to the Canon well dog Phoenix
is ostensibly an adaptation of the x-men
story of the same name it's also a
conclusion to the new x-men timeline
that started in x-men first class as the
surviving members of that film beast
mystique Professor X and Magneto all get
endings to their unique hogs there's a
reason for that as beast tells mystique
join the Tesla party were the last of
the first class with Darwin killed in
the first movie angel and banshee killed
off screen in Days of Future past and
havoc killed in Age of Apocalypse only
beast mystique Charles and Erica around
to remember the swinging 60s that's also
why audiences see beasts in charge of
the gene crate school at the end of the
film he's the most senior x-men around
who's not busy playing chess and
Parisian cafes magneto seems to have let
go of his anger and Charles have removed
himself from his school in order to not
let his ego continue to do damage
mystique dies trying to help Jean which
is less a conclusion to a arc than its
actress Jennifer Lawrence's ongoing
attempts to extricate herself from the
ex franchise anyway because the x-men
clip watch don't watch I don't care what
Michael Fassbender's magneto has come a
long way from 2011's x-men first class
he hasn't forgotten the past he might be
leading the island nation
of Genosha and acting as a father figure
to a sanctuary of mutants but Magneto's
got his own lock box of Secrets just
like gene in Eric's case that lock box
contains us telepathy proof helmets and
the newspaper clipping that references a
standoff against the x-men on the White
House lawn in x-men Days of Future past
both objects aren't exactly points of
pride for the former mutant terrorists
the helmet was previously worn by the
Nazi scientist who killed Erik's mother
and the clipping references the time
magneto was almost killed by his
ex-lover mystique that's some heavy
baggage to keep around the house with
dark Phoenix looking to be the end of
the x-men franchise as we know it there
are plenty of glances back to the past
before we head off into that wild
unknown future and by the way the women
are always saving the men around here
you might want to think about changing
the name to ex women well Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby might have created the
original x-men the larger X franchise
owes a huge debt to chris claremont
claremont as a co-creator of pretty much
all of your favorite x-men and he
spearheaded the direction of the X
Universe for over 20 years from the Dark
Phoenix saga to God loves man kills it's
no exaggeration to say that the x-men's
popularity as we know it is largely a
product of Claremont's collaborations
with artists like Dave Cockrum John
Byrne and Jim Lee in terms of the x-men
Claremont shadow looms nearly as large
as Stan Lee's own fittingly the
filmmakers behind Dark Phoenix saw fit
to give Claremont a cameo in the film
during the scene in which Charles Xavier
is accepting the accolades for the x-men
successful rescue of the endeavour
spaceship Claremont can be briefly seen
in the crowd well the x-men movie
universe has gone through two timeline
shifts and multiple actor recasting z'
some things like Eric and Charles
never-ending chess game never changed by
the end of Dark Phoenix everyone has
moved on beast is running the school
Jean Grey's become an immortal flame
bird creature in the sky and Charles is
hanging out in Paris Erik arrives and
badger Simmons are playing a game of
chess as a movie ends it's a fitting end
to a long and twisting franchise while
the film's had many endings Charles and
Erik's ongoing chess game remained a
major motif it's a nice way to not to
the fact that although the franchise
will be ending as x-men gets absorbed
into Disney and the MCU some things will
continue on
we have a great swell of pity for the
poor soul who comes to that school
looking for trouble check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite x-men
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]